Oh sent and called Joseph
because he had talked to his,
his Butler and they brought him hastily
out of the Dungeon and Joseph shaved
himself and changed his clothes
and came in unto Pharaoh.
I guess he didn't want to shock pharaoh
with how people dressed in the prison.
And Pharaoh said Unto Joseph,
I've dreamed a dream and there
is none that can interpret it.
And I've heard say if d that you can
understand the dream to interpret it.
And Joseph said,
it's not me.
Ah,
God will give Pharaoh and answer of peace.
It's so Jacob isn't taking credit
for his ability to interpret dreams,
which also indicates quite interestingly,
there's,
there's nothing that despite the fact
that he's successful and competent,
he's not narcissistic.
Like if he happens to have this gift,
he regards it as a gift
and not as something that,
you know,
redounds his favor.
It's just something that he
happens to be able to do.
And so that's,
that's a hallmark of someone who's got a
pretty well put together personality as
far as I'm concerned because you know,
people have gifts that
they didn't really earn.
Those would be your talents,
your intelligence,
your good looks if you
happen to have good looks,
et Cetera,
and they're not,
there's no sense being all puffed
up about that because it's,
it's great.
It's luck of the draw though and the
proper attitude is to note that it's luck
of the draw and to be grateful for it.
Yeah,
it's quite a fine painting.
That one
hold their come seven years of great,
plenty throughout the land of Egypt and
then there shall arise after them seven
years of famine and all the Plenti
shall be forgotten and the famine shall
consume the land and the Plenti
shall not be known in the land.
I reason of that famine
following sh fort Shelby,
very grievous.
So now we see to that Jacob,
he can interpret dreams,
but he's also the sort of person who can
look into the future and think this is
sort of what Adam was called on to do
when he got kicked out of the garden of
Paradise is you're going to be able to
conceptualize that even if things are
going well now,
that that doesn't mean that they're
going to go well into the future.
And so he's the aunt
and not the grasshopper,
right in the grasshopper
and the ants story,
it's like everything's good,
but you should wake the hell up and you
should test to see how things can go
wrong and you can see if your
systems can survive them.
Things going wrong and which is something
that I think we could all Harken to
because I think we do a very bad job in
the modern world of testing to see if
our systems can go wrong.